zu gast sind und ich darf herzlich
danken dem sender phoenix der gebärden
dolmetscher für uns bereit stellt und
dort zu sehen ist sind die damen des
heutigen tages ich darf herzlich danken
dem sender phoenix der gebärden
dolmetscher für uns bereit stellt und
dort zu sehen ist sind die damen des
heutigen tages aber auch nur dort wird
sie haben uns verschiedene dinge
mitgebracht sind haben das wort ja meine
damen und herren guten tag
dieser tag begann mit der schrecklichen
nachricht vom tod des bundestags
vizepräsidenten thomas oppermann
die bundeskanzlerin hat wie politiker
aus allen parteien ihrer bestürzen ihrer
trauer über diesen viel zu frühen tod
bereits ausdruck gegeben ich darf
vielleicht noch einmal zitieren dass sie
ihn über viele jahre hinweg als
verlässlichen und fairen
sozialdemokratischen partner in großen
koalitionen geschätzt hat er war
bundestags-vizepräsidentin turbulenten
jahren und hat sich um unser parlament
verdient gemacht was thomas oppermann
auszeichnete war besonders das was man
vielleicht eine freundliche
demokratische ernsthaftigkeit nennen
kann mit der politik gemacht hat mit der
er auf die menschen zugegangen ist die
bundeskanzlerin hat seiner frau und
seinen kindern ihr aufrichtiges beileid
ausgesprochen und die sitzung des corona
kabinetts heute vormittag zu der wir
sicherlich inhaltlich nachher noch
kommen begann mit einer schweigeminute
der trauer und des gedenkens an thomas
oppermann
ich würde dann gerne kurz auf aktuelle
entwicklungen im verhältnis zwischen der
türkei und frankreich zu sprechen kommen
die bundesregierung hat äußerungen des
türkischen präsidenten erdogan über den
französischen präsidenten emanuel makro
zur kenntnis nehmen müssen dass sind
diffamierende äußerungen die ganz und
gar inakzeptabel sind erst recht vor dem
hintergrund der schrecklichen mordtat
eines islamistischen fanatiker sun dem
französischen lehrer samuel partie bei
dieser gelegenheit möchte ich auch die
aussagen zurück weisen die präsident
erdogan in richtung deutschland gemacht
hat dass es sich nämlich bei der
polizeilichen durchsuchung einer moschee
in berlin kreuzberg am vergangenen
mittwoch um eine gegen den islam
gerichtete maßnahme gehandelt habe
die deutschen polizeibehörden arbeiten
auf der grundlage von recht und gesetz
wer in deutschland friedlich und
innerhalb der gesetze seinen glauben
lebt der ist von unserer verfassung
geschützt wenn also unterstellt wird
eine solche aktion habe eine
diskriminierung einer
religionsgemeinschaft einer gruppe von
gläubigen als basis dann ist das
gänzlich falsch und dann würde ich gerne
noch eine terminankündigung machen die
diesen mittwoch betrifft um 13 uhr wird
die bundeskanzlerin in einer
video-konferenz einen erneuerten
austausch mit den ministerpräsidenten
und ministerpräsidentin über die lage in
der pandemie haben und es wird zu
beraten sein was getan werden kann um
die ausbreitung des virus möglichst bald
wieder einzudämmen mittwoch 13 uhr
jetzt könnte ich
übergehen zum corinna kabinett aber das
können wir auch anders machen ja ich
mache jetzt glaube ich gerade
unterstützung wird es ist ein bisschen
viel auf einmal da wird's ein bisschen
durcheinander auf einmal ich nur zu
denen die hier online fragen stellen wer
hier sein wer sich nicht ausweist wer
ist dessen fragen werde ich hier auch
nicht vortragen
frage gibt es zum thema türkei
nachfragen und hessen
die frage ist fühlt sich deutschland die
bundesregierung sozusagen auch wenn die
erdogan äußerungen gegen die person x
cross zielte mit betroffen da es ja
offenbar auch um lebensraum und werte
geht und zum zeitplan eine frage
vielleicht ans auswärtige amt frankreich
hatte als erste maßnahme seinen
botschafter aus ankara abgezogen herr
seibert hat erwähnt dass auch gegen die
durchsuchung der moschee in deutschland
von erdogan und zutreffende vorwürfe
gemacht wurden ist ein gespräch oder
eine einbestellung des türkischen
botschafters eine überlegung oder
einplanen oder schon gemacht worden
natürlich ist es ein zeichen der
solidarität wenn ich im namen der
bundesregierung wenn auch der
außenminister heute morgen zu diesem
thema ja bereits etwas gesagt hat also
ganz klar gemacht hat dass für uns
äußerungen wie sie gegen den
französischen präsidenten gerichtet
wurden inakzeptabel sind betrachten sie
es als ein zeichen der solidarität und
der gemeinsamen werte
zu ihrer frage vergessen was die
handlung des auswärtigen amtes angeht
herr seibert hat erwähnt der
außenminister hat sich heute morgen zu
der situation geäußert
und er hat auch unter anderem gesagt
dass wir großes verständnis haben für
die diplomatischen mit maßnahmen die
frankreich ergriffen hat wenn wir eigene
maßnahmen ergreifen haben geht werden
wir das an dieser stelle hier
kommentieren aber im moment kann ich
ihnen dazu nichts berichten
bitteschön
wie bewährt die bundesregierung dass die
polizisten frühmorgens in eine moschee
gestürmt sind mit stiefeln schuhen auf
den gebieten gelaufen sind und die
gläubigen mit einem gebet gestört worden
sind über den konkreten einsatz kann ich
sicherlich im namen der bundesregierung
kann aus keine aussage machen ich kann
ihnen lediglich sagen dass unsere
polizei im bund wie im ländern auf der
basis von recht und gesetz und erst
recht auf der basis der grundgesetzlich
garantierten religionsfreiheit agiert
eine religionsfreiheit die für
angehörige aller glaubensrichtungen gilt
insofern ist der in richtung deutschland
gemachte vorwurf als werde der islam
diskriminiert mit einer solchen aktion
grundsätzlich zurückzuweisen
dazu weitere fragen
das scheint mir nicht der fall zu sein
mit dem mittwochs ankündigungen sind wir
ja beim thema corona wenn ich das
richtig so zusammenfassen
noch kurz aus dem corona kabinett ja ja
ich und der ihre erklärung zum tod von
thomas oppermann steht glaube ich für
sich da würde ich jetzt keine weiteren
fragen zu aufrufen bitte sie haben das
wort ja heute vormittag gab es eine
weitere sitzung der bundeskanzlerin mit
den zuständigen fachministern zu themen
der pandemie also das was man das corona
kabinett betrifft das treffen die
beratungen beginnen wie es immer ist mit
einem lagebericht heute durch den
zugeschalteten bundesgesundheitsminister
abgegeben die zahlen kennen sie alle wir
haben einen drastischen anstieg von
neuinfektionen
an diesem montag grob gesagt doppelt so
viele wie am montag vor einer woche
und dieser drastische anstieg führt zu
einer in vieler hinsicht ernsten
situation
der anteil der korona fälle in der
älteren bevölkerung nimmt wieder zu
in zahlreichen
ist eine nachverfolgung jedes einzelnen
der kontakte jedes einzelnen infizierten
nicht mehr möglich weil die
infektionszahlen einfach zu hoch sind
trotz des großartigen einsatzes der
mitarbeiter und mitarbeiterinnen in den
gesundheitsämtern die krankenhäuser
verzeichnen eine deutliche zunahme von
kobe 19 erkrankte auch auf den
intensivstationen
auch die zahl der patienten die
künstliche beatmung benötigen steigt
wieder deutlich die bundeskanzlerin hat
auch an diesem wochenende oder am
vergangenen wochenende wieder
eindringlich an uns alle appelliert
unsere kontakte deutlich zu reduzieren
es liegt in unser aller verantwortung es
liegt auch in unser aller händen wie
sich die fallzahlen im herbst und winter
weiter entwickeln ein weiteres thema im
kabinett waren die koordination der
intensivmedizinischen kapazitäten wie
sie wissen es gibt ein intensiv register
das täglich die freien und die belegten
intensivmedizinischen
behandlungskapazitäten in deutschland
erfasst
dieses register enthält auch aktuelle
zahlen über corona patienten die
intensivmedizinisch betreut werden und
dieses register ermöglicht engpässe in
der intensivversorgung frühzeitig zu
erkennen es ermöglicht entsprechend zu
handeln und eben gegebenenfalls wenn es
an der einen stelle keine weiteren
kapazitäten mehr gibt corona erkrankte
menschen patienten zu verlegen und dafür
das können sie sich vorstellen bedarf es
eines entsprechenden konzepts um bei
drohender regionaler überlastung der
intensiv kapazitäten schnell reagieren
zu können und für eine patientin
verteilung sorgen zu können ein solches
konzept wurde vom bmi und vom
bundesgesundheitsministerium vorgelegt
des weiteren ging es um die
impfstrategie sobald ein oder mehrere
sichere zuverlässige impfstoffe
zugelassen werden erfolgt die lieferung
entsprechend der produktion nach und
nach es ist daher wichtig für diese
phase eine strategie zu erarbeiten
welche personenkreise zuerst geimpft
werden sollten und wie die impfungen
analysiert werden können dazu kann ihnen
sicherlich das
bundesgesundheitsministerium näheres
mitteilen
das waren die wesentlichen themen im
corona kabinett heute und ansonsten habe
ich ihnen gesagt am mittwoch eine
weitere beratung zwischen bund und
ländern in form einer video-konferenz
das gesundheitsministerium nicht sehen
kann anschließen
die leopoldina die stiko und der
ethikrat sind gerade dabei ein konzept
zu erstellen wonach die risikogruppen
die in impfstoff zuerst bekommen sollen
und das wird dann priorisiert und dafür
wird gerade ein konzept erstellt herr
krämer
sie hatten ich hatte ein gesamt nicht am
anfang gibt es beschlüssen beschluss
erwartet am mittwoch
ich kann ihnen hier noch keine
beschlüsse vortragen logischerweise aber
natürlich findet dieses treffen zwischen
der kanzlerin einigen ministern und den
ministerpräsidenten in der derzeitigen
sich zuspitzenden ernsthaften lage statt
und die gemeinsame frage die alle sich
stellen müssen wie können wir möglichst
schnell dazu kommen dass sich die
infektionszahlen der wuchs der
infektionszahlen stabilisiert um die
tendenz dann auch wieder den trend dann
wieder zu brechen und die zahlen nach
unten zu bringen und allen ist denke ich
bewusst das hat uns die letzte woche die
letzten 14 tage sehr klar gemacht dass
dabei jeder tag zählt also rechne ich
auch mit beschlüssen aber ich kann dem
heute hier nicht vorgreifen das wird wie
immer gut vorbereitet werden dann kann
ich anschließend die online frage des
kollegen jeff carr von zdf heute der sie
fragt herr seibert ob die kanzlerin
30.000 neuinfektionen in der kommenden
woche für möglich hält
mit allem respekt vor dem frager ich
glaube es ist sinnlos jetzt hier zahlen
voraussagen zu machen
wir haben eine entwicklung bei der von
letztem montag auf diesem wir leider
eine verdoppelung nahezu der fallzahlen
gesehen haben es ist völlig klar wohin
das führt wir hatten am freitag oder
samstag weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr
bereits 14.000 neuinfektionen gemeldet
an einem tag wenn wir es nicht schaffen
durch konsequentes handeln auf allen
ebenen dieses tempo der ausbreitung der
pandemie zu brechen dann werden wir noch
zu ganz anderen zahlen kommen aber es
ist wirklich nutzlos jetzt hier einzelne
zahlen in den raum zu stellen
unser augenmerk muss darauf liegen und
ich denke das ist auch das thema dann am
mittwoch was können bund länder
gemeinsam tun um möglichst schnell
diesen trend zu brechen ja frage ans bmg
sollten sich nach ihrer einschätzung die
kliniken und auch die patienten sich
jetzt darauf einstellen planbare
operationen zu verschieben macht das
sinn
oder halten ist für übertrieben und wenn
ja wann
dazu hatte der minister sich ich glaube
vor etwa zwei wochen selbst noch mal
geäußert und bislang gibt es genug
kapazitäten was das betrifft aber wie
hier ist in zukunft aussieht das kann
ich ihnen jetzt nicht sagen
der minister hat immer wieder appelliert
sich an die hygiene regeln zu halten
abstand zu halten und auf den anderen zu
achten damit es nicht dazu kommt dass
die krankenhäuser ausgelastet sind dann
komme ich nochmal zurück auf die
anstehende treffen mit den
ministerpräsidenten
welche maßnahmen
fragt kollege bockenheimer von bild
könnten bei der an bei dem anstehenden
treffen verschärft werden ohne in den
lock down zu gehen ganz konkret sind
auch temporäre ausgangssperren wie in
unseren nachbarländern möglich und ist
mit einschränkungen des schulunterrichts
zu rechnen
ich möchte ausdrücklich bei der linie
bleiben die ich vorhin gesagt habe und
jetzt nicht einzelne maßnahmen
zwei tage vor dem treffen hier durch
spekulieren
beide seiten die sich da begegnen die
vertreter der länder und die vertreter
des bundes und die bundeskanzlerin
wissen dass dies eine ernste situation
ist in der wir mit politischer
konsequenz herangehen müssen und das
wird sich dann auch in den beschlüssen
niederschlagen aber ich möchte hier
keine einzelnen maßnahmen diskutieren
es hat sie hatten es schon kurz
angesprochen die bundeskanzlerin hat
eine videobotschaft gemacht und wie hat
sie wiederholt sie ist meine frage sie
hat ja die begründung der videobotschaft
die wiederholung der videobotschaft
damit begründet dass sie beim ersten mal
nicht verfangen hat macht das den sinn
dann eine botschaft zu wiederholen wenn
man schon sagt sie hat nicht fangen wäre
es dann nicht sinnvoll eine andere
botschaft man das hat die
bundeskanzlerin gebogen und die zweite
frage die bundeskanzlerin sich mal sehr
sensibel was polizeigewalt angeht den
weißrussland gerade wiederholt
kritisiert völlig zurecht und es läge
mir völlig fern weiß was dann mit der
bundesrepublik zu vergleichen und gab es
aber am wochenende und der rabiate
szenen der rechtsanwalt heinz ist wie
auf dem alexanderplatz umgerempelt
worden ist eine zierliche freundin gegen
eine hauswand geschleudert und ohne er
einen vergleich ziehen zu wollen
oder etwas reis zu setzen ist die frage
sieht die bundeskanzlerin so etwas auch
mit sorge sie werden jetzt sagen recht
und gesetz ist gewährleistet den verein
verstanden aber es gibt ja immer wieder
ausnahmen gibt ja auch verurteilungen
sieht die bundeskanzlerin
auf max das war ausführlich so zwei
verschiedene themen habe ich sie in dem
erst in der ersten frage richtig
verstanden dass sie gesagt haben nicht
verfangen waren das die worte die sie
benutzt genutzt sagt also entschuldigung
dann es ist einfach für reitschuster ist
es einfach falsch schauen sie sich den
podcast an
da werden sie die begründung der
bundeskanzlerin hören und das was sie da
insinuieren ist in dieser begründung
nicht drin
zweitens wenn es ihnen fern liegt
belarus mit deutschland zu vergleichen
dann würde ich sagen lassen sie es
einfach ich habe hier keine weiteren
einsatz bewertungen vom wochenende
vorzunehmen das wird dort einmal
geschehen wo der einsatz geschieht
nämlich in diesem fall in berlin ich
habe dazu nichts zu sagen aber lassen
sie einfach diese vergleiche mit denen
sie sich schon in der frage wie an
heranpirschen also die variante in der
bundespressekonferenz ist frage
nachfrage oder zwei fragen dann gehe ich
weiter in der runde hat zu dem treffen
am mittwoch nur ums klarzustellen es war
ja ursprünglich glaube ich der 30
oktober im gespräch gewesen dass es
jetzt praktisch dass es das ist da
alternativtermin jetzt es gibt nicht
zwei termine nächste woche in dieser
woche richtig
also ich könnte ja auch sein dass von
zwei terminen in dieser woche ist nicht
die rede
dies ist der termin der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
bundeskanzlerin in dieser woche gut und
da so weit ich heute montag schauen kann
ok und dann mit blick auf dieses treffen
hatte die kanzlerin
laut berichten ja gesagt dass sie kein
besonders gutes gefühl habe es werden
sie wahrscheinlich sagen das war ein
internes gespräch und das wollen sie
nicht kommentieren
aber tatsache ist dass das letzte
gesprächen in der taten nicht viel
gebracht hat und insofern kann man ja
schon ein bisschen pessimistischer
dieses weitere gespräche wie warum meint
die kanzlerin jetzt in diesem gespräch
dann mehr zu erreichen können als in
einem letzten gespräch mit dem
ministerpräsidenten
erstens stellen sie das nicht ganz
richtig da wenn sie sich an die
pressekonferenz der bundeskanzlerin und
der beiden ministerpräsidenten nach der
letzten mpk nach dem letzten treffen
erinnern dann hat die bundeskanzlerin
die dort beschlossenen beschlüsse
ausdrücklich begrüßt gelobt und als
wichtige schritte bezeichnet sie hat
gleichzeitig gesagt dass ihre unruhe im
betreff auf die ganze situation damit
noch nicht vorüber sei und nun hat sich
die situation seit dem jedenfalls nicht
zum besseren entwickelt im gegenteil
also gibt es immer noch grund für diese
unruhe gibt es immer noch grund für
dieses gefühl der dringlichkeit und mit
diesem gefühl der dringlichkeit wird die
bundeskanzlerin in die mittwochs
beratung gehen äußerungen die in
internen runden gemacht werden
die kommentierten i2 verständnisfragen
herbert weil sie herrn spahn
angesprochen hatten ist davon auszugehen
dass es ihm fällt dass man sich gut geht
hat er dann update gegeben und ist davon
auszugehen dass das restliche kabinett
seit letzten mittwoch getestet wurde und
zwar negativ getestet wurde
zu der zweiten frage sind sie jetzt ein
bisschen spät das haben wir in beiden
pressekonferenzen der letzten woche
ausführlich behandelt und da würde ich
gerne auch darauf verweisen und zu der
ersten frage gucke ich die kollegin aus
dem gesundheitsministerium an die über
ihren chef noch besser berichten kann
der minister geht es den umständen
entsprechend gut er herzlich gestern in
im video noch einmal für die
genesungswünsche bedankt und ja das war
es eigentlich so jetzt hatten wir aber
auch zwei fragen wann das gilt dann auch
für alle gleich gern gräber nämlich
wieder auf die liste dann direkt dazu
heißt es dass es noch leichte
erkältungssymptome gibt oder was heißt
das konkret
ja er hat erkältungssymptome aber die
sind jetzt nicht schlimm aber er hat
erkältungssymptomen gibt es jetzt noch
fragen zum gesundheitszustand des
gesundheitsministers im moment nicht so
dann mache ich jetzt weiter bei einer
über zwei fragen die online gekommen
sind und zwar fragt der kollege sascha
meyer von dpa wie viele gesundheitsämter
haben aktuell an das robert koch
institut gemeldet dass die engpässe bei
der kontakt nach verfolgung haben oder
dass dies bei ihnen absehbar ist und
dazu passt die frage von nick leifert
aus meiner sicht vom zdf der fragt
welche strategien die bundesregierung
alternative denkbar wenn die kontakt
nachverfolgung teilweise schon jetzt
nicht mehr funktioniert ach so und dann
auch noch anno fricke von der ärzte
zeitung ist mit einem strategiewechsel
bei der nachverfolgung berechnen hin
cluster orientiert das passt glaube ich
alles in den kontext
das müssen sie mit herrn seibert klären
ob sie danach so fragen sie doch mal an
schauen wir weiter also ich möchte noch
mal darauf hinweisen dass die cluster
strategie zu der strategie zur unsere
strategie schon immer gehört hat die
geht vor den einzelfällen auch und
eine andere strategie ist mir jetzt auch
nicht bekannt die wird weiterhin so
verfolgt und auf der internetseite des
rk ii werden die einzelnen punkte wie
jetzt kontakte nachverfolgt werden und
wie so genannte cluster herausgefunden
werden auch noch einmal erläutert und
erklärt sehr ausführlich auch gut ich
habe jetzt noch farbig noch mal hin
jessen einen jungen und herren
reitschuster zu diesem thema ist sonst
noch jemand dazu dann möchte ich das
thema auch schließen damit wir noch
etwas weiter kommen
dann geht es weiter mit den worten herr
seibert sie hatten bereits vor zwei
wochen angesprochen dass die schweren
krankheitsverläufe weiter zunehmen das
haben sie jetzt noch mal betont bisher
machen sie aber abstand davon genommen
da konkrete zahlen nachzureichen oder
damit ihre aussage zu untermauern da
würde mich nur interessieren wenn sie
mittlerweile der lage das auch in
konkreten zahlen zu belegen diese
signifikante zunahme an schweren
krankheitsverläufen in den letzten
wochen dazu waren wir immer in der lage
und ich bedauere es wenn sie da auf eine
nachreichung gewartet hatten und die aus
irgendwelchen gründen nicht gekommen war
denn wir können natürlich genau benennen
die zahl der patienten der korona
patienten die intensivmedizinisch
betreut werden müssen wir können genau
benennen die zahl der koma patientin
auch die ist jetzt deutlich gestiegen
die beatmet werden müssen und man weiß
ja leider dass trotz aller medizinischen
fortschritte ein signifikanter teil
derjenigen die beatmet werden müssen die
krankheit auch nicht überleben wird ich
werde ihnen wir werden ihnen diese
nachfrage nach diese diese zahl
nachreichen ich dachte das sei geschehen
sie sollten aber nicht daraus schließen
dass wir nicht in der lage sind die
zahlen auch die behauptungen die wir
machen auch mit zahlen zu unterlegen
dazu sind wir absolut in der lage aber
ich muss es also stand
sechsundzwanzigster zehnter 8 uhr sollte
der 26 zehnte ja dann kann ich ihn
aktuell von 1.300 4
corona patienten die intensivmedizinisch
behandelt werden berichten und kann
sagen dass da von 592 invasiv beatmet
werden und man könnte nun über seit ende
september eindeutig zeigen wie beide
indikatoren intensivbehandlung und
künstliche beatmung wie die deutlich
gestiegen sind
das war noch nachfrage eine nachfrage
ins gesundheitsministerium
letzten montag wollten sie die
medienberichte nicht bestätigen dass
derzeit ein gesetzentwurf zirkuliert in
der internen ministerien abstimmung in
dem geplant ist die sonderrechte kontext
der korona krise zu verstetigen könnten
sehen sich mittlerweile der lage
zumindest diese berichte zu bestätigen
dass dieses würding des verstetigen der
sonderrechte in der aktuellen vorlage so
fällt ja also letzte woche hatte ich
gesagt dass der entwurf noch einen
abstimmungen ist und entwurf ist
weiterhin in abstimmung und der minister
selbst hat sich auch letzte woche noch
mal dazu geäußert also dass ich habe
jetzt keine aktuelleren informationen
dazu ja auch ins gesundheitsministerium
vor fünf tagen hat an dieser stelle ihr
sprecher kollege erklärt auf die
entsprechende frage
es gebe man habe keine anhaltspunkte
dafür dass sozusagen eine um sich
greifende nicht mehr nachvollziehbarkeit
von kontakten gebe jetzt haben wir aber
genau diese situation wie kann sich das
innerhalb von fünf tagen ändern wussten
wir es damals nicht besser sind sie
komplett überrascht worden das sind ja
zwei sehr weit auseinanderdriften der
aussage und situationen wie zum zweiten
der vorstandsvorsitzende des verbandes
der medizinischen laboren die 90 prozent
der chor der der gofit tests durchführen
sagt die kapazität von bei einer million
test pro woche können dauerhaft nicht
aufrecht erhalten werden und er beklagt
eine falsche prioritätensetzung die von
der politik verlangen
wird wie gehen sie mit dieser kritik zu
ihrer ersten frage kapazitätsengpässe
werden an das lka weitergeleitet die
gesundheitsämter sagen dem robert koch
institut wo engpässe sind und da sind
stetig abstimmung absprachen und zu
ihrer zweiten frage zu einzelnen
äußerungen kann ich mich hier auch nicht
äußern
kommentiert nicht ja aber das ist nicht
einfach eine einzelne äußerungen sondern
das ist der der mann herr müller spricht
für 90 oder für die labore die 90
prozent der tests praktisch durchführen
und wenn der sagt wir können die
kapazität nicht aufrecht erhalten und
durch die maßnahmen der bundesregierung
wird falsch priorisiert das ist nicht
irgendeine beliebige äußerung da müssen
sie sich doch dazu verhalten ist ein
direkter als sie ihre konkrete frage
also fragt sie hat die konkret eine
konkrete frage ist werden sie können sie
eine eine stellungnahme ihres hauses zu
dieser fachlich von fachlich kompetenter
seite vorgetragenen kritik nachliefern
das einzige was ich sagen kann ist dass
wir die strategien immer wieder
überprüfen und anpassen und zu einzelnen
äußerungen kann ich mich wie gesagt
schauen sie wenn ich das sagen darf in
dieser pandemie ist doch nicht statisch
und genau das was die kollegen gesagt
hat dass auch test strategien immer
wieder angepasst werden müssen
das kann man doch jetzt auch sehen wir
haben natürlich durch die enorme
ausweitung der infektionen gemeldet
werden
jeder dieser infizierten menschen hat
kontakte diese kontakte müssen sofern es
direkte kontakte waren natürlich auch
getestet werden sofern man sie überhaupt
erreichen kann
das heißt schon das führt natürlich zu
einer inanspruchnahme von vielen tests
mehr als in der zeit als
300 infektionen am tage meldeten
und das heißt das sind die wand die
wechselnden bedingungen in dieser
pandemie die immer wieder dazu führen
dass die bundesregierung natürlich alle
alle elemente ihrer corinna politik ihre
vorsorge politik auch up to date bringen
muss zwei fragen herr sorg gibt es ein
kommentar von ihrer seite zum
brandanschlag auf ein gebäude das lka am
wochenende
und wie ist das bei den test kapazitäten
wenn die jetzt knapp werden muss dann
müssen sie zum beispiel die
privatwirtschaft zurückstecken
es gibt ja zum beispiel die bundesliga
die zigtausende test jede woche nutzt
ich glaube die hatten auch angeboten
falls die test kapazitäten für die
bevölkerung knapp werden dass die dann
ihre kapazitäten zur verfügung stellen
zu dieser ersten frage ich hoffe dass
sich herausstellen wird und dass man
denjenigen oder diejenige finden kann
die einen brandsatz gegen das gebäude
des robert-koch-instituts geworfen haben
ich bin sicher dass die polizei da das
beste tut um den auch den oder
diejenigen auch zu finden
wir müssen insgesamt aufpassen
in dieser pandemie die für alle eine
belastung es dass wir nicht dazu kommen
bestimmte gruppen bestimmte zum beispiel
wissenschaftler zb die presse zu
verhöhnen wir haben am wochenende bilder
gesehen eines einer einer puppe um deren
hals sowie presse ein schild gehängt war
und die von irgendeiner brückenbau mitte
sowas ist widerwärtig und zeigt ein
denken dem wir uns alle gemeinsam
entgegenstellen müssen und zum teil höre
ich auch und sehe ich auch gegen
wissenschaftler ein solches denken
gerichtet ich erinnere mich an
demonstrationen hier in berlin bei denen
bilder gezeigt wurden von
bekannten virologen hinter gittern so
wir müssen alle zusammen aufpassen dass
wir dieser atmosphäre der verachtung und
des persönlichen angriffs keinen raum
geben und dass wir uns dem
entgegenstellen
darüber hinaus hoffe ich einfach dass es
gelingen wird herauszufinden wer diesen
brandanschlag verübt hat zweite frage
umverteilung von test des kapazitäten
also das hat der minister auch gesagt
also dass wir dass es nicht dazu kommen
kann dass die kapazitäten nicht mehr
gegeben sind und also wir können jetzt
nicht in die zukunft schauen und sagen
was dann passieren wird wenn die
kapazitäten nicht mehr vorhanden sind
daher kann ich mich dazu jetzt nicht
weiter äußern
ja aber wenn das prinzip gilt zwei
fragen oder eine frage eine nachfrage
muss es irgendwie herr schuster nächste
mal kurz zum prozedere der herr
regierungssprecher hat er mich gefragt
was ein missverständnis aber wenn in
einer antwort gefragt wird wer ist
eigentlich fair wenn man dann noch mal
nachfragen dürfte aber jetzt zum
gesundheits antworten also vielen dank
zum gesundheitsminister überlassen sie
das mir weil ich habe hier die leitung
dieser pressekonferenz überlassen aber
das was ich mir wünschen würde wenn er
gefragt werde vom sprecher in einer
antwort man auch diese also liefern darf
aber jetzt vielleicht haben sie auch
eine frage gehört in einer frischen
nachfrage meist anderes in den letzten
tagen vermehrt berichtet dass ein
fußballverein bei 4 fußballverein auch
bayern münchen ist es gab zunächst
positiv waren die sich dann aber als
negativ heraus stellten bei
nachrüstungen es gab auch kritik zu
einem führenden forschungslabor ist sie
sagten gerade diese billigen tests
zeigen sich zuverlässig weil sie dass er
gehen leichtfertig mit anderen bewohner
verwechseln und hier wäre die frage ist
es korrekt von neuinfektionen zu
sprechen wie das was er auch getan hat
wenn es positive tests sind und wie hoch
ist die fehlerquote wie wollen sie
sicherstellen dass auch
normalsterblichen zweites mal testen
können wie fußball profi ist wie sich
das leisten können also ich kann mich
jetzt nicht zu einzelnen testprodukten
äußern ich weiß nicht welche tests da
eingesetzt wurden und und eigentlich
kann ich mich dazu auch nicht weiter
äußern und das rki hat auch auf der
internetseite dazu informationen wie es
ist bei falsch positiven testergebnissen
dass es tatsächlich dazu kommen kann und
es gibt eine gewisse prozentzahl und das
bild auch sehr transparent kommuniziert
heute denn jetzt noch eine nachfrage
dann verlassen wir das thema nur die
bitte wenn sie vielleicht diese
prozentzahlen noch liefern können und
bereits zwei tests möglich wäre wenn man
das noch machen können dann habe ich
sehr dankbar vielen dank so jetzt habe
ich frau pauli mit einem neuen thema und
dann nehme ich mal meinen anschutz hier
ab es geht um die proteste in thailand
die seit monaten andauern
die jetzt auch die demonstranten bis vor
die deutsche botschaft dort führen
proteste gegen den könig der welten oder
als so oft nicht in seinem eigenen land
weilt in deutschland gerne es dort gerne
feiert und möglicherweise von dort aus
regiert meine frage ist der
bundesaußenminister hat er schon
angedeutet dass das möglicherweise
konsequenzen haben muss als so nicht
geht nicht nur weil sich der könig nicht
ein chor ohne regeln hält sondern eben
das regieren sozusagen von deutschland
aus nicht gehe
welche konsequenzen könnten denn drohen
und wie
kroatisch muss man darum gehen damit man
nicht einen tatsächlichen eklat auch
hatte so was gibt es da von
möglichkeiten vorzugehen gegen den könig
zu wirksamer sie haben recht der
außenminister hat sich heute vormittag
in einer pressekonferenz mit dem die eu
chefs auch zum thema machen oder
anlässlich dieser pressekonferenz auch
zum thema thailand geäußert und er hat
unter anderem gesagt natürlich folgen
verfolgen wir die entwicklung die es den
thailand gibt dass es demonstrationen
gibt menschen die ihre rechte auf die
straße gehen er hat auch gesagt wir
prüfen das nicht nur in den letzten
wochen sondern wir prüfen das auch
dauerhaft fort und wenn es dort dinge
gibt die wir als rechtswidrig empfinden
dann wird das sofortige konsequenzen
haben das zunächst mal einmal das
vollständige zitat was was die
konsequenzen angeht so möchte ich hier
nicht auf einzelheiten gehen und auch
nicht spekulieren darüber welche
konsequenzen
tatsächlich getroffen werden können oder
maßnahmen sondern zunächst einmal die
äußerungen des ministers von heute
vormittag für sich stehen lassen ganz
kurze nachfrage was wären denn für
konzentriertes herrichten
so wiesen sammelsurium vermutlich mal an
konsequenzen sondern was konnte man da
machen könnte man ihnen dann ausweisen
wird unerwünschte person erklären
einfach nochmal ein eindringliches
gespräch mit ihm führen also was ist da
sozusagen am besteck auf dem tisch wie
gesagt über speck ich möchte an dieser
stelle nicht spekulieren darüber welche
konsequenzen in betracht gezogen werden
können hamburger und frau adebar haben
sich in den vergangenen wochen mehrfach
auch zur zur lage geäußert auch der
tatsache dass der könig sich teilweise
in zeitweise in deutschland aufgehalten
hat und diese äußerungen stehen erstmal
für sich und dann geht es weiter mit
henderson dazu die die äußerung war ja
auch man werde nicht zulassen dass der
könig von deutschland aus regieren
erstens auf welcher rechtsnorm beruht
sozusagen dieses wenn man so will verbot
oder diese nicht legitimität und
zweitens welches sind die kriterien an
denen sie feststellen können dass
regiert wird so regierungschefs sind ja
im grunde immer im dienst wenn man auch
im ausland also was das kriterium wo sie
sagen das ist jetzt regierungshandeln
das nicht
die team ist und gegen das garn schreibt
zunächst einmal die bundesregierung ist
überzeugt davon und erwartet auch dass
keinesfalls von hier aus entscheidungen
getroffen werden die der deutschen
rechtsordnung dem völkerrecht oder den
international verbrieften
menschenrechten widersprechen das haben
hamburger und frau adebar wie ich schon
erwähnt habe mir vor an dieser stelle
hier deutlich gemacht ich kann ihnen
freiburgern frage warum auch mehrfach
deutlich gemacht dass wir diese
situation beobachten
derzeit hält sich der köthener
thailändische könig nicht in deutschland
auf das heißt im moment geht es nicht um
die frage was welche welche maßnahmen
hier in deutschland ergriffen werden
sondern im moment beobachten wir einfach
die lage in thailand selber und möchten
deswegen an der stelle auch nicht darauf
eingehen welche maßnahmen getroffen
werden können ihnen bestimmten szenarien
die sich im moment nicht stellen ich
hatte auch nicht nach den nachfrage nach
nach konkreten maßnahmen gefragt sondern
ich verstehe sie jetzt rechtlich richtig
dass es sich nicht um regierungs
handlungen an sich handelt die sie
kritisieren sondern um solche die gegen
deutsches recht lingen völkerrecht gegen
menschenrechte verstoßen würden oder
sagen sie regieren an sich geht nicht so
hatte ich den außenminister verstanden
die rechtliche lage gestaltet sich so
dass es völkerrechtlich unzulässig ist
hoheitsakte auf fremdem staatsgebiet
vorzunehmen und das bezieht sich ebenso
wie auf den thailändischen könig in
deutschland wie auch andere
staatsangehörige anderer nationen in
deutschland ich habe jetzt noch ein
junger und herrn delfs zu diesem thema
und würde das thema dann auch verlassen
aber auch der trainer auch zu diesem
thema ich hab nicht ganz verstanden wie
sie es prüfen ob hoheitsgebiet zu lande
durchgeführt werden wie können sie das
prüfen
die details kann ihnen sagen dass wir
mit der thailändischen regierung in
ständigem kontakt stehen auch zu der
frage wo sich der könig aufhält und ob
er sich in deutschland ganz konkret
auffällt wie wir das prüfen darüber kann
ich ihnen im moment keine auskunft geben
entschuldigung wenn sie die
thailändische seite fragen die wir ihnen
natürlich das sagen was sie hören wollen
wir haben über die gespräche mit der
thailändischen seite hinaus
selbstverständlich noch andere
möglichkeiten zu überprüfen was der
könig genau macht wenn er sich in
deutschland aufhält wie gesagt im moment
hält er sich nicht in deutschland auf
das heißt im moment stellt sich diese
frage nicht
das ist eine frage die richtet sich an
das auswärtige amt oder vielleicht auch
an die sprecherin des
gesundheitsministeriums des wagens
direkt mal gefragt und da liegt gar
nicht so ein könig auch jetzt diesen
coroner reisebeschränkungen also wenn
ich das richtig verstehe der reist dann
immer von thailand nach münchen hin und
zurück die ganze zeit soll angeblich
nächste woche wieder kommen musst du
denn eigentlich in quarantäne oder wie
ist das mit könig kann so ein und
ausreisen oder wie wird das gehandhabt
ist ja potenziell auch ein
infektionsrisiko dieser mann
wer von ihnen möchte was ich dazu sagen
kann ist dass die
regel natürlich für alle gelten
wir haben jetzt keine ausnahme
aufgestellt dazu aber vielleicht kann
das ok das innenministerium kann
beantworten wie kritiker sagen werden
nicht zu kündigen aber zu
einreisebeschränkungen allgemein es gibt
ja eine positivliste für staaten für
deren angehörige die
einreisebeschränkungen nicht gelten
diese positivliste wurde angesichts der
teilweise eine verbesserung der
epidemiologischen lage in verschiedenen
staaten im sommer aufgesetzt und diese
positivliste umfasst zurzeit australien
neuseeland singapur thailand und uruguay
das erklärte krämer nochmal der könig
soll sich angeblich auch sorgen machen
dass er nicht mehr einreisen darf nach
deutschland gibt es dafür gibt es dafür
eine begründung die man anführen könnte
dass man ihn nicht reinlassen würde
abgesehen von corona ich kann jetzt nur
für diese von dieser positivliste
besprechen entsprechenden zu starten für
diese diese einreisebeschränkungen nicht
gelten
bitte herr selbst jetzt noch mal das
würde ja den rückschluss eigentlich
heißen solange tyler nicht auf der
positivliste war hätte ja auch gar nicht
einreisen können richtig wäre dann ja so
aber ich meine es erinnern es ist läuft
das doch schon länger dieses hin und her
reisen zwischen thailand und münchen zu
den reiseaktivitäten kann ich jetzt
selber nicht sein aber es gelten in
jedem fall die keine missstimmung dazu
könnt ihr vielleicht noch jetzt noch mal
ein letzter aufruf zu thailand herr
reitschuster so dann aber auch wirklich
wenig der fall hier machen nach einer
stunde schluss nicht das ist hier die
zielgröße das war hier die frage ob der
könig in kanada muss bin ich falsch
informiert oder unterliegen
stadtoberhaupt häupter in dieser
hinsicht überhaupt nicht mehrheitlich
rechnen
wem geht müssten sie mal weiter geben
wie sie die quarantäne bestimmungen sind
die einzelnen bundesländer zuständig da
kann ich keine einer koalition zu machen
wir haben jetzt hier noch eine reihe von
themen doch ich hatte jetzt dazu
niemanden mehr
jetzt zum frau dann zu dem thema andere
anderes thema jetzt habe ich aber noch
wir beenden das thema jetzt zugreifen
rat bitteschön moment passt das mikro
jetzt ich kann es auch leider nicht mehr
sehen deshalb keine szenen ist ja jetzt
ja ich sehe es nicht mehr wenn sie
verdeckt ist kann ich nicht mehr sehen
ob's leuchte okay ich habe eine frage an
das auswärtige amt an frau saß und zwar
ist in der letzten woche eine deutsch
iranerin im iran festgenommen worden
ich möchte gerne wissen auf welchem
stand die konsularische betreuung ist
und was sie überhaupt zu dem fall wissen
ob sie kurz um geduld bitten weil ich
die unterlagen
das ist so das heute der fall und
selbstverständlich bekannt ist und wir
uns auch für die damen einsetzen
wir haben allerdings bisher noch keine
offizielle bestätigung über die
inhaftierung erhalten und bemühen uns
gegenüber den iranischen behörden um
aufklärung des falles und seiner details
über die details des falles selber
soweit sie uns denn bekannt sind können
wir natürlich wie immer aus gründen des
persönlichkeitsschutzes nichts sagen es
dazu weitere fragen das schauen wir
nicht der fall zu sein
herbedes war das auch zwei frauen das
bundesverkehrsministerium noch einmal
wechseln bitte
[Musik]
ich würde einmal interessieren dass die
leute gutachten über das am wochenende
berichtet worden ist der erste auftrag
gebe sie der bund oder das maut
konsortium und liegt ihnen eine art
verfahrens kalender bereits vor zum
schiedsgerichtsverfahren
ich bitte sie um verständnis dass ich
nicht hier in dem rahmen nicht zum
schiedsgerichtsverfahren äußern kann
können sie ausschließen dass es einen
termin gibt bereits für den abschluss
des schiedsgerichtsverfahrens ich kann
nur sagen dass mir ein solcher termin
nicht bekannt ist dazu weitere fragen
das scheint nicht der fall zu sein habe
ich dann war ich noch mit einem anderen
thema dann habe ich auch noch einige
online fragen eine frage ganz
verteidigungsministerium
die deutsche luftwaffe hat in den
letzten oktober wochen gemeinsam mit
nato alliierten die übung steht fest nun
durchgeführt also das anbringen und
abwerfen von us atomwaffen in
deutschland trainiert laut
eigendarstellung der nato geschah dies
ich zitiere zur verteidigung des
bündnisgebietes hatte ich nur eine
verständnis frage heißt es dass das
trainieren des abwurfs von us atomwaffen
durch deutsche tornados auf deutschem
staatsgebiet in der nato logik unter
verteidigung des bündnisgebietes fällt
zudem der nuklearen teilhabe habe ich
die auch schon einiges gesagt
und was die übungsinhalte angeht auch
hier sind wir schon sehr eindeutig
gewesen dass wir zu den details der
umsetzung keine angaben machen dass ich
die informationspolitik der
bundesregierung hinsichtlich der nuklear
streitkräfte der nato aus
sicherheitsgründen an die geheimhaltungs
regeln das bündnis ist ausrichtet und
ich kann da über das hinausgehen was was
sie vielleicht von der nato gehört haben
nichts keine angaben machen aber es ist
ja auch schon relevant auch für das
gesamtverständnis der bundesdeutschen
bevölkerung zu wissen ob deutsche
tornados atomwaffen abwürfe testen auf
deutschem territorium im verständnis
dass dies der bündnis bei der
verteidigung des bündnisgebietes gilt
für die details der übung verweise ich
auf die geheimhaltungs regeln den ich
hier unterliege es ist insgesamt so das
natürlich das was militärisch geplant
ist auch geübt werden muss und in diesem
fall sind das internationale übungen die
auch die luftwaffe involviert war und zu
weiteren anhalten kann ich hier keine
stellung beziehen
ich habe jetzt noch eine frage die so im
weitesten sinne dazu passt
ich hab's gesehen hier richtet sich an
phrase aber vielleicht auch an sie das
weiß ich jetzt noch nicht ganz genau von
der nachrichtenagentur tass von kessler
philipp oft da muss ich jetzt passen auf
dass ein weiblicher oder männlicher
vorname ist eine frage an das auswärtige
amt an frau saß und an herrn seibert
russlands präsident wladimir putin hat
die nato-staaten verzicht auf die
stationierung landgestützte atomarer
kurz und mittelstreckenraketen
aufgerufen
im gegenzug wolle moskau seinen
mittelstreckenwaffen des typs 9m 729
nicht im europäischen raum aufstellen
sagt putin wir wie bewertet die
bundesregierung
diese äußerung richtet sich anziehen ok
und sind diese meldungen bekannt dass
russischen präsidenten ist es auch nicht
neu russland hat bereits mehrfach in der
vergangenheit ein solches moratorium
oder den verzicht angekündigt
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg hat
sich unter anderem letztes jahr dazu
geäußert vor dem hintergrund dass es ja
russland selber war ein land was aus dem
vertrag ausgestiegen ist hat
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg diese
äußerungen oder die möglichen verzicht
für unglaubwürdig gehalten und wir
schließen uns dieser einschätzung an
der junge noch nachfragen zum thema
atomwaffen
da gab es letzte woche was neues nämlich
dass honduras als 50 der start der
un-vertrag zum verbot von atomwaffen
ratifiziert hat damit wird das un
atomwaffen verboten in 90 tagen in kraft
treten und damit deutschland nicht teil
dieses vertrages sein
essens lern frage ist das der erste
internationale un völkerrechts vertrag
wo deutschland nicht dabei ist und wann
planen sie diesen vertrag beizutreten
und integrativ ii zieren ja ich glaube
man muss da mal etwas grundsätzliches zu
sagen damit es nicht zu verwechslungen
kommt auch bei denen die uns jetzt zu
hören wir müssen unterscheiden zwischen
dem atomwaffensperrvertrag und dem
atomwaffen verbots vertrag
der atomwaffensperrvertrag oder der
nuklearen nichtverbreitungsvertrag wäre
auch genannt wird ist von den fünf
atommächten usa frankreich china
großbritannien und sowjetunion initiiert
worden und hat mittlerweile über 190
vertragsstaaten der kern dieses
atomwaffensperrvertrages ist es dass die
nationen die nicht im besitz von
kernwaffen sind auf deren erwerb auch
verzichten
deutschland hat diesen vertrag schon
1970 ratifiziert der atomwaffen verbots
vertrag über den sie nun reden und über
den weg nun reden
der hat zum ziel die entwicklung die
produktion test
bewerb lagerung transport stationierung
und den einsatz von kernwaffen zu
verbieten
wir haben hier häufig unsere haltung zur
situation nukleare bewaffnung
dargestellt die situation in der welt
zeichnet eben ein anderes bild als der
atomwaffen verbots vertrag
es zeichnet und wir dürfen nach unserer
festen überzeugung nicht die augen davor
verschließen dass nukleare waffen von
einigen staaten immer weiterhin noch als
mittel der militärischen
auseinandersetzung betrachtet werden und
solange das so ist und deutschland und
europa davon auch bedroht sind besteht
aus unserer sicht die notwendigkeit zum
erhalt einer nuklearen abschreckung fort
diese leiste die nato für uns die
bundesregierung steht unverändert und in
vollem umfang zur defensiv
ausgerichteten nuklear strategie der
nato und vor diesem hintergrund ist atom
ist deutschland dem atomwaffen verbots
vertrag nicht beigetreten
hessens plädiert oder setzt sich die
regierung immer noch für eine
atomwaffenfreie welt ein und habe ich
nicht verstanden dass herr seibert dass
auch deutschland atomwaffen als mittel
militärische auseinandersetzung immer
noch sieht also der teil der nato und
die nato sieht das auch so sie
wiederholen also sie möchten jetzt dass
wir etwas wiederholen was wir hier
wirklich viele male dargelegt haben
nämlich unsere überzeugung dass
natürlich wir uns eine atomwaffenfreie
welt wünschen dass wir aber auch die
realitäten sehen und da sehen wir dass
einige staaten nukleare waffen nach wie
vor als ein mittel der militärischen
auseinandersetzung betrachten und dass
deswegen eine nukleare abschreckung wie
die nato sie gewährleistet derzeit noch
notwendig ist und solange das so ist hat
deutschland ein interesse daran an allen
strategischen diskussionen und
planungsprozessen innerhalb der nato
auch teilzunehmen und das ist der grund
warum wir den atomwaffen verbots vertrag
nicht beitreten während wir dem
atomwaffensperrvertrag sei
50 jahren angehören ich sehe dort keine
weiteren fragen dann habe ich noch eine
frage zu einem anderen thema der
kollegin für sarah von der presse
agentur interfax
sie will eine bestimmte frau sucht nach
einer bestätigung der frage ob es stimmt
dass russlands präsident wladimir putin
nach eigener darstellung habe er alexei
navalny nach dessen vergiftungen selbst
die ausreise nach deutschland ermöglicht
und zwar habe er bei der
staatsanwaltschaft darum ersucht den weg
für ein reines behandlung frei zu machen
obwohl es gegen den 44-jährigen
beschränkungen wegen anhängiger
strafverfahren gebe
die frage die sich stellt ist ob es ist
ob das so richtig ist also zunächst
einmal kann sie sich ja an den kreml
wenden um etwas bestätigt zu bekommen
oder auch nicht welche schritte zu der
ausreise von herrn navalny geführt haben
die für ihn für sein überleben für seine
genesung für seine familie so wichtig
war das kann ich hier nicht kommentieren
dann gestimmt dann da gibt es noch eine
frage von dem weg zu ja generell
kraushaar navalny könnte das
justizministerium und ein update geben
wie der stand ist er mittlerweile glaube
ich vier rechtshilfeersuchen von
russischer seite an die deutschen
behörden bzw
entsprechenden staatsanwaltschaften
vielen dank ich habe hier keinen neuen
stand zu berichten gegen bei dem was
meine kollegen den letzten vorletzter
woche gesagt haben
der stand zu ihm rechte versuchen ist
unverändert das heißt unverändert heißt
es gibt es hat er trägt er mittlerweile
monate das auf alle vier
rechtshilfeersuchen es bisher keine
reaktion vom bundes deutscher seite gibt
meine kollegen wir schon ausgeführt dass
wir zum inhalten können wir uns
grundsätzlich nicht äußern zu diesen
inhalten der grenzüberschreitenden
strafrechtlichen zusammenarbeit und ja
es ist unverändert alle versuchen werden
von der wegen des sozialen systems
bearbeitet derzeit aber ich würde ein
bisschen ob seine reaktion gab auf eines
der vier wie gesagt zu den jetzt
inhalten kann ich mich stellen ihnen
hier
sie wurden alle vier an die berliner
justiz weitergeleitet das wissen sie
darüber haben wir hier gesprochen
ich habe jetzt auf meiner liste noch
kein reitschuster noch mal und noch eine
frage von dpa online können wir damit
dann hier heute schließen das sieht mir
sehr sie haben jetzt eine frage ok dann
warten wir auch noch mal und dann sind
wir für heute durch dann geht es mit
zwei fragen wie eigentlich nehme mal an
verbraucherschutz vielleicht verkehr bei
der bahn gibt es immer wieder
beschwerden von reisenden dass sie auch
mit masken attest des zuges verwiesen
werden wie ist die eigene schätzung
rechtlich vom verbraucherschutz herbeck
dass das hausrecht wenn man einen masken
attest hat sie sind ja auch mit eigener
der bahn die bundesregierung und die
zweite frage es ist verbraucherschutz
das westschweizer fernsehen hat einen
test in auftrag gegeben bei fest ex da
wurden masken getestet von acht
stoffmasken waren sieben unbefriedigend
die lassen sogar tröpfchen durch also
sex kann man alles recherchiert
von den op masken waren nur vier
ausreichend und da ist die frage hat das
verbraucherschutzministerium vor da eine
forschung tests in auftrag zu geben oder
was möchten sie bewegen damit die masken
auch zuverlässig getestet werden und
damit sich der verbraucher darauf
verlassen kann dass es eben nicht so ist
wie jetzt in der schweiz wo von den acht
getesteten stoffmasken 7 fast alles
durch lassen ja vielen dank für die
fragen die wir treffen jetzt hier geht
den gesundheitlichen verbraucherschutz
deshalb mit ist das
gesundheitsministerium federführend
dafür zuständig dass bis zum die
kollegen dagegen teils beantworten
können sie sich das vorher bitte zur
qualität der masten
das lka hat empfehlungen dazu auch
veröffentlicht welche masten sich eignen
da findet man eine liste dazu und da
können sie auch nachschauen und auch die
bürgerinnen und bürger welche masken
am besten sind trumpf für die nutzung
die erzählung finden sie dort und zu den
tests in bahn
das ist mir nicht bekannt und können sie
sich dazu äußern wenn sie sich nicht
dazu äussern können da müssen wir hier
auch nicht plätze wechseln also ja ich
glaube sie müssen wir bei der bahn
nachfragen
ich würde einfach empfehlen vielleicht
dass sie die user ihres blogs hinweisen
auf die zahlreichen informationen die es
vom bundesgesundheitsministerium vom
robert koch institut auch von der
bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung über den wert und nutzen des
masken tragen es genauso wie über die
gesundheitsverträglichkeit des masken
tragen es gibt da gibt es sehr sehr gute
sachen ja ich hab noch mal ne frage ans
bmi die eigentlich noch zum komplex
corona gehört aber vorhin eben nicht
gepasst hat
der bundesinnenminister hat sich ja im
frühjahr sehr sehr starke macht reise
bewegung einzuschränken in der
überzeugung dass dadurch die
infektionsrisiken gesenkt werden jetzt
ist davon überhaupt keine rede mehr
ich weiß dass neulich hier schon mal
kurz gesagt wurde das ist jetzt im
moment nicht vorgesehen ist enorm
reisebeschränkungen innerhalb eines
einzigen aber ich hätte jetzt doch gern
mal eine erklärung hat herr seehofer das
für einen irrtum im nachhinein erklärt
oder ist jetzt die lage so ganz anders
damals aber wie kommt es dass das thema
überhaupt nicht mehr auf den tisch ist
und ich hätte ganz kurz dazu auch noch
gerne stellungnahme von herrn seibert
wie die kanzlerin das sieht ob es
vielleicht in ferner zukunft sowas oder
auch lehrer wieder geben könnte oder ist
das ganz vom tisch
für die frage ich kann ihnen zusagen
dass die frage ist auch am letzten
freitag schon gestellt worden dass die
bundesregierung und das
bundesinnenministerium die situation und
die entwicklung des pandemie geschieht
sehr genau beobachten und maßnahmen auch
immer wieder angepasst werden können und
müssen ist derzeit aber keine
überlegungen gibt die vorläufig bin von
grenzkontrollen wieder einzuführen
ja das war mir bekannt aber warum was
ist der unterschied zu früher
wie gesagt muss die anlage in jedem fall
neu angepasst werden
neu überprüft werden und massnahmen
angepasst werden der derzeitige stand
ist der den ich jetzt schon gesagt habe
mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen
ich habe sie mir jetzt nichts
hinzuzufügen
und dann bin ich hier noch mit einer
online frage am start von teresa dapp
von dpa die das bundesumweltministerium
fragt der chef der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde raphael gross sie hat
gesagt es sei praktisch ausgeschlossen
die globalen klimaziele ohne atomkraft
zu erreichen teilt die bundesregierung
insbesondere das umweltministerium diese
auffassung
das ist relativ wenig überraschend wenn
jemand dessen job ist die atomkraft zu
werben
das eben auch dafür wirbt insofern ist
das erst mal interessant aber die
position der bundesregierung ist ja klar
der bund der ausstieg aus der atomkraft
ist beschlossene sache 2022 soll das
letzte atomkraftwerk abgeschaltet und
dafür gibt es entgegen der behauptung
von den großen tatsächlich auch
technische gründe
und jetzt in die details zu gehen ist
das aber tatsächlich etwas wo wir sagen
wir sind auch gespannt zuhören was herr
rossi sagen kann zu dem problem der
atomkraft eben mit sich bringt denn zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt kann wir noch keinen
standort auf der welt wo es ein endlager
gibt was tatsächlich auch funktioniert
und betragen betrieben wird gut dann
danke ich darf für und frau werden wir
jetzt kann ich auch das mikrofon
danke ich hab noch mal ganz schnell eine
frage an das verteidigungsministerium
der ksk zwischenbericht war für ende
oktober angekündigt worden
können sie sagen wann der veröffentlicht
wird uns in welcher form danke schön
sind hinsichtlich des ksk
zwischenberichts im zeitplan bis ende
oktober wird dieser bericht durch den
generalinspekteur der ministerin
vorgelegt und daran anschließend wird es
bei der ersten sich bietenden
gelegenheit im parlamentarischen raum
eine kommunikation geben eine
information zum sachstand und zu den
ausstehenden maßnahmen und entsprechend
unmittelbar danach wird auch die
öffentlichkeit informiert
gut dann sind wir heute durch was gibt
es noch für eine frage ich hatte jetzt
aber alle aufgerufen ob es noch fragen
gibt ja dazu habe ich eine frage zu
dieser frage aber dass das zentrum für
politische schönheit hat heute eine
aktion gestartet wie ihn also der
bundeswehr helfen will die waffen wieder
zu finden wie bewerten sie in dieser
hilfsaktion es ist ein bisschen gequält
dass das zu dem thema ist
dem weg gehe habe ich mir auch als
kultur interessierter mensch einmal
angeschaut und bekannt ist ja dass das
zentrum für politische schönheit solche
künstlerischen aktionen bevorzugt ich
denke die aussage des künstlers der ist
hier nichts hinzuzufügen ich möchte das
auch nicht gut dann danke ich allen für
ihr kommen